j'ouvre notre second thème vous le savez
il est volontairement décalé de
l'actualité consacrée ce soir au crit
des espoirs poussés par les femmes en
Afghanistan depuis le retour au pouvoir
des talibans c'était en juillet 2021
leur liberté disparaissent les unes
après les autres c'est s'ils le 8 mars
elles ont manifesté à leur manière des
femmes afghanes se sont rassemblés chez
elle pour demander le droit de retourner
à l'école
nous demandons à l'émirail islamique de
rouvrir les portes des écoles des
universités et des bureaux aux femmes
afin qu'elles puissent recevoir une
éducation et que grâce à cette éducation
elle puisse servir leur pays et
contribuer à son progrès
car depuis l'arrivée des talibans au
pouvoir en août 2021 les droits des
femmes se sont dégradés outre
l'interdiction d'aller à l'école et à
l'université les femmes ne peuvent plus
exercer en politique elles étaient près
de 30% au Parlement avant le changement
de régime elles ne peuvent plus non plus
voyager sans être accompagnés par un et
ont été bannis des jardins publics des
conditions dégradées condamnées par les
Nations Unies
l'Afghanistan c'est le pire des pires et
c'est l'exemple qui devrait être pour
tout le monde dans les pays du Nord
comme du Sud un rappel de ce à quoi la
pensée perverse peut conduire supprimer
les femmes de cette manière et sans
équivalent
les Nations Unies dénoncent également
exclusion des femmes de nombreux
secteurs professionnels elles ne peuvent
par exemple plus travailler dans les ONG
un drame dont ce pays où les besoins
d'aide humanitaire sont très importants
les femmes sont des travailleuses
essentiels et cruciales dans le secteur
humanitaire en plus du fait qu'elles ont
des droits et il faut qu'elle retourne
au travail pour le moment ces
protestations internationales restent
sans effet les talibans continuent de
durcir un peu plus les droits des femmes
dans leur pays
je présente tout de suite les invités de
ce second débat Solène Chalon fiority
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes grand
porteurs et d'actrice du documentaire
réalisatrice de documentaire afghane qui
a été publié diffusé le 12 mars dernier
sur France 5 et puis ce livre la femme
qui s'est éveillée qui lui est publiée
aux éditions Flammarion Karine pazad
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes chercheur à
l'Iris spécial Afghanistan et vous avez
enseigné à l'université de Kaboul
caroleman bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
sociologue spécialisé dans la
problématique du genre et du conflit
armé et puis créatrice de cette ONG
femme aide qui aide notamment les femmes
en Afghanistan et avec sur les enjeux
d'éducation vous nous en parlerez
évidemment en détail dans un instant et
Mathieu croissando est resté à mes côtés
je commence avec vous ce lundi fiority
donc ce documentaire que vous avez pu
réaliser en Afghanistan diffuser le 12
mars qui donne la parole
à des Afghans vous étiez encore il y a
une dizaine de jours c'est ça dans dans
le pays cette parole que les talibans
leur confisquent comme tout le reste
qu'est-ce qu'il leur reste aujourd'hui
de leur vie d'avant juillet 2021
alors malheureusement pas grand chose ça
dépend quand même de qui on parle c'est
à dire que entre les femmes à la
campagne et les femmes en ville il y a
toujours en Afghanistan mais comme dans
beaucoup d'autres pays du monde une
fracture très nette ce qui est certain
c'est que pour les filles des villes ce
qui leur reste en fait c'est
l'apprentissage de la lecture je
caricature à peine et le droit de
travailler dans les centres de santé
parce que même si elles ont encore le
droit de travailler dans le secteur
privé la crise économique est-elle qu'en
réalité les Afghans ont aussi bon dos de
tout mettre d'une certaine manière sur
le dos des talibans parce que aussi
beaucoup d'entreprises qui doivent se
séparer d'une partie de leurs effectifs
et les contrôles sont tellement rigides
de la part des talibans sur le secteur
privé qu'en fait on a on a voilà on a
vite fait de faire partir les effectifs
féminins donc les Afghans ont quasiment
tout perdu et pour celles de la campagne
même si elle ressentent moins évidemment
ce changement de régime extrêmement
brutal il faut quand même dire qu'elles
ont faim puisque la crise humanitaire
qui touche l'Afghanistan en ce moment
touche 90% des Afghans et donc oui elles
ont elles n'ont pas de il n'y a pas de
violence directement en dehors de chez
elle mais enfin elles ont faim donc
c'est une situation qui s'attaque en
fait à toutes les femmes quel qu'il soit
quelle qu'elle soit dans le pays car
même pas exact on a cru pas longtemps
que que cet aliment 2021 était moins
rétrograde que leur prédécesseurs ils
avaient fait des promesses sur les
droits des femmes ils n'ont jamais
promis
qui respecterait et de voir les femmes à
chaque fois qu'il était interrogé par
par les médias occidentaux exemple il
faisait oui les femmes ils auront tous
les droits mais ajouté une phrase que en
Occident on ne comprenait pas trop dans
le cadre de la charia voilà tout ça tout
est dépend de ça c'est à dire
le regard est enlevant sur les femmes
sur le travail des femmes sur sur les
droits des formes etc c'est une charia
c'est-à-dire les lois ISL qui dit que tu
es et c'est la raison pour laquelle quoi
tout à l'heure peut-être qu'on reviendra
les raisons pour laquelle nous dirons
qui expliquent les bons sont aussi
strictes sur
les droits des femmes c'est une
interprétation extrêmement
rigouiste même fanatique des lois
islamiques que c'est loin existent c'est
ça la raison il y a d'autres raisons
aussi qui expliquent la position des
talons caroleman que on essaye de c'est
évidemment très difficile mais pour des
jeunes femmes qui s'apprêtaient à
devenir médecin ingénieur professeur
enfin quelle est leur état de désespoir
aujourd'hui
absolue leur état de désespoir et
vraiment extrême il y a des cas de
suicide de dépression chronique elle
voudrait fuir elles sont enfermées c'est
effrayant c'est effectivement très dur
pour celles qui s'apprêtaient à
commencer à travailler en dernier de
faculté
alors il y a une il y a des libertés qui
sont tombées un peu les unes après les
autres depuis juillet 2021 et au mois de
décembre on a appris que les universités
seraient désormais interdite aux femmes
je vous propose des réactions
d'étudiantes ou d'anciennes étudiantes
des femmes qui ont été rencontrées par
nos confrères de l'Agence France Presse
et je ne peux pas décrire avec les mots
ce que j'ai ressenti le jour où j'ai
appris l'interdiction d'aller à
l'université s'ils avaient ordonné la
décapitation des femmes tout de suite ça
aurait été mieux que cette interdiction
nous sommes traités d'une manière encore
pire que celle réservée aux animaux les
animaux peuvent aller n'importe où mais
nous les filles nous n'avons même pas le
droit de sortir de chez nous
ils ont tout fermé pour nous les parcs
les piscines tout et maintenant le seul
espoir que nous avions était d'aller à
l'université vitamine nos études de
devenir un bon médecin et de servir
notre société mais ils nous ont pris
cela aussi
je pense que j'ai enterré mes rêves
vivants de mes propres mains il ne reste
plus qu'à respirer nous sommes des
personnes mortes avec la capacité de
respirer
nous sommes des personnes mortes avec la
capacité de respirer je vous avoue que
cette phrase elle va me rester en tête
pendant pendant longtemps si on rentre
l'accès par exemple l'accès à l'espace
public qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui quel interdictions
s'appliquent aux femmes arabes il faut
bien comprendre qu'il y a une vraie
hiérarchie qui est pas du tout c'est
l'Afghanistan c'est pas la France donc
nous bien sûr si on nous prive demain
Carole et moi de conduire on va se
révolter en réalité moi en 12 ans
d'Afghanistan de correspondance en
Afghanistan j'ai vu deux femmes con une
voiture dans ma vie entière vous voyez
les mesures prises au départ étaient des
mesures qui en réalité d'ailleurs nous
ont tous un peu endormi parce qu'on a
pensé qu'elles étaient prises sans doute
pour flatter les lieux et que d'une
certaine manière en fait elle ne
changeait pas réellement le quotidien
des Afghans donc je vous parle du permis
de conduire mais il y a aussi
l'interdiction de voyager bon jamais
dans notre vie d'Afghanistan on a vu des
femmes voyager seul c'était la guerre
depuis 40 ans ça ne se faisait pas du
tout en revanche ensuite il y a une
bascule effectivement la bascule c'est
là encore d'abord attaquer à l'espace
public les parcs mais là c'est pareil si
vous voulez hormis les grandes capitales
provinciales et kabouls des parcs en
réalité où ce mélange des hommes et les
femmes vous les comptez quasiment sur
les doigts des deux mains donc on a
imaginé que c'était voilà des de même
que d'ordonner ces polices cette police
religieuse de la répression de vie on a
imaginé que c'était une certaine manière
une forme de vitrine voilà du nouveau
régime Taliban et ensuite est tombé
l'interdiction deux interdictions
majeures qui transforment complètement
le quotidien des femmes afghane
aujourd'hui c'est l'interdiction de à
l'école sachez que toutes les filles
aujourd'hui au-dessus de 12 ans 3
millions de gamines en Afghanistan sont
privés d'enseignement secondaire alors
qu'en 20 ans on avait multiplié par 5 le
nombre des gosses qui allait à la fois
au collège au lycée à l'université et
ensuite autre décision prise en plus
beaucoup plus tard ce qui montre bien
que les talibans sont sur une autoroute
beaucoup plus grave encore puisqu'elle
touche les femmes qui sont démunies de
tout ils interdisent aux femmes de
travailler dans les ONG si vous
travaillez pas dans les ONG ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas de femmes qui va venir
obtenir un coupon de nourriture pour
accéder à la nourriture d'urgence donc
en fait il y a pas de femme qui profite
de des aides d'urgence donc ça c'est un
appauvrissement supplémentaire c'est ça
l'exclusion des femmes afghane de
l'économie nationale ça coûte 5
milliards de dollars c'est pas moi qui
le dis c'est c'est l'ONU donc les
talibans en plus sont dans une stratégie
de sabotage économique complètement
folle il y a aussi une interaction du
hammam c'est ça avec des conséquences en
termes de santé publique comment est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça oui on peut le dire
parce que il faut bien voir que la
majorité de la population est
extrêmement pauvre et donc le hammam la
salle de bain c'était comme les c'est
bien pire encore que les Bains Douches
pour nous il y a un siècle beaucoup de
familles n'ont pas de salle de bain donc
ce lieu de se laver et une forme de
sociabilisation parce que la fin de
l'école la fin de d'une mixité même
entre femmes signifie que les femmes
sont extraordinaires m'ont isolées chez
elles
c'est extrêmement dur
ne constitue pas vraiment une force
politique homogène homogène idéologique
c'est-à-dire l'interprétation de
islamiques et aussi en terme politique
c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous avez posé la question espace public
pour les femmes c'est vrai tout ce que
vous avez dit est vrai et la plupart des
espaces publics
que les femmes fréquentées auparavant
sont maintenant fermés mais quand même
il y a d'autres espaces politiques qui
publient qui qui sont ouvertes pour les
femmes et ça c'est contre toi ça c'est
par exemple aujourd'hui à Kaboul des
femmes des femmes pauvres ouvrir des
restaurants fréquentés par des femmes
c'est à dire le risque de cuisinier
jusqu'à garçon
il y a aucun homme ne peut pas entrer
dans ses restaurants ce que je sais pas
ce souci peut-être inventé un terme
espèce publique je sais pas quoi
féminine ou uniquement féminine ou
espace public des femmes selon l'état
allemandes en fait je ne sais pas je
veux dire on est dans une situation ou
même en termes sociales mais surtout en
terme politique l'étalement
ne montre pas un certain homogénéité ça
veut dire que vous voyez un peu
dubitatif sur sur cet exemple là non
mais simplement bon quel restaurant ou
comment si une femme peut pas sortir
seule elle doit être accompagnée d'un
homme pour aller où que ce soit donc ça
voudrait dire que pour aller dans un
restaurant de femmes si toutefois les
moyens de se payer le restaurant ce dont
je doute énormément elle devrait être
accompagnée d'un homme qui la quitte à
la porte non pour moi excusez-moi c'est
vraiment cosmétique ça existe ça existe
peut-être mais c'est bon ça ça me
faisant ça existe effectivement j'en ai
vu la Kaboul mais c'est il faut bien
voir dans quelles conditions comme dit
caroleman c'est à dire que il y a encore
des très petits sanctuaires du féminin
c'est à dire on est aliment n'entre pas
mais je rappelle qu'en fait ces
espaces-là sont fermés aussi les uns
après les autres cette bibliothèque de
femmes merveilleuse à Kaboul faut savoir
que les filles elles ont continué ces 20
dernières années essayer de produire un
petit peu de littérature des petites
maisons d'édition des clubs de poésie
etc résultat ils ont fermé une une des
dernières bibliothèques de filles la
semaine dernière donc en fait ces
espaces sont visés parce que c'est ça
qui est intéressant qu'il faut
comprendre c'est à dire que le problème
des talibans n'est pas réellement si
d'une certaine manière vous pouviez
bouger une boîte de femmes d'un endroit
à l'autre ça irait je vous assure je
caricature à peine ce qu'il ne faut pas
ce qui est inacceptable pour eux c'est
la sortie dans l'espace public c'est la
rue les talibans le disent bien ils ont
pas un problème avec l'éducation sinon
ils arrêtaient les radios communautaires
les télévisions ils feraient tomber
toutes les écoles clandestines comme le
réseau de caroleman qui qui est encore
très vivace aujourd'hui ils ne le font
pas pourquoi ils le font pas parce que
c'est pas l'éducation qui leur pose un
problème c'est l'école c'est le
déplacement c'est le fait que les femmes
soient dehors et en fait et là encore
malheureusement je crois qu'on se dirige
vers un scénario encore plus triste que
ce qui se dessine déjà parce que même
ces petits espaces de femmes fermées ou
les filles furtivement franchement dans
des conditions de courage physique
extraordinaire toute planquée se dirige
vers ces espaces et bien même là il les
arrête parce que vous pensez bien qu'il
y avait pas d'hommes
dans les hammam pour se laver aux côtés
des femmes mais ils vont dire parce que
c'est toujours leur rhétorique qu'ils
ont eu des plaintes parce qu'on a appris
qu'une fille s'est montré devant une
fenêtre ou que celui qui recevait
l'argent au hammam c'était en fait un
homme voyez c'est ce genre de de
scénario en fait qu'il les février même
si vous pouvez tout à fait attester du
fait que les deux sexes ne se mélangent
jamais alors je propose à Steve Jordan
de nous rejoindre parce qu'on voulait
c'est poser la question est-ce qu'il y a
une résistance
interne une résistance afghane Steve
bonsoir rebonsoir et bienvenue est-ce
qu'il y a une résistance qui tente de
survivre comme ça à l'intérieur d'une
résistance alors il y a beaucoup
d'expert ici hein je vais essayer de de
présenter quelques figures de la
résistance et une résistance qui est un
carnet notamment par Mark Booba Saraj 74
ans journaliste militante des droits des
femmes c'est pas n'importe qui c'est une
véritable figure dans son pays elle
occupe une place un peu à part elle est
la nièce d'un roi qui a régné sur
l'Afghanistan au début du 20e siècle
elle a ses entrées à l'ONU et dans les
instances internationales où elle
s'exprime régulièrement elle a une
histoire un peu singulière qu'elle a
quitté l'Afghanistan en 78 au moment de
l'arrivée des communistes elle a vécu en
exil pendant près d'un quart de siècle
avant de revenir en 2003 à Kaboul où
elle a fondé une ONG qui vient en aide
aux femmes elle a un passeport américain
elle aurait donc pu partir au moment du
retour d'état Liban mais elle a choisi
de rester pour se battre écoutez là
III bien sûr j'aurais pu partir mais je
suis resté en Afghanistan la raison pour
laquelle je suis resté c'est parce que
j'aime vraiment ce pays j'ai pensé que
quelqu'un devait être ici
mon travail me battre pour ces femmes
et me dresser face au taliban en leur
disant c'est ce que je fais et c'est
comme ça que je vais le faire
la défense des droits des femmes elle
passe aussi STEVE par les réseaux
sociaux oui c'est d'ailleurs peut-être
la grande différence avec la première
prise de pouvoir des talibans en 96
aujourd'hui il y a une vraie bataille
pour la conquête des esprits sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est un espace que les
femmes témoignent des abus commis par
les talibans elles peuvent aussi mettre
en scène leur désobéissance civile comme
par exemple cette jeune Zara qui s'est
confiée à nos confrères du Huffington
Post en réaction à l'interdiction des
universités elle est descendue dans la
rue pour taguer sur les murs de Kaboul
mort au taliban éducation travail
liberté la vidéo ensuite très largement
été diffusée et relayée sur les réseaux
sociaux on va voir aussi comment la
contestation s'organise à l'étranger
fouillez avec souvent une dimension un
peu plus symbolique un les 58 jeunes
musiciens de l'Institut National de
Musique d'Afghanistan ont fui leur pays
il y a un an et demi ils vivent
aujourd'hui à Braga au Portugal où il
tente de sauver leur art on rappelle que
les talibans ont interdit de chanter et
de jouer un instrument en dehors des
airs religieux shogunfa j'espère que je
prononce bien shogunfa est une
percussionniste de 19 ans elle aime
Beethoven et rêve de pouvoir un jour
retourner dans son pays écouter là
il est très difficile d'être musicien
surtout pour une femme surtout dans un
pays comme l'Afghanistan c'est très
difficile vous savez pour l'État Liban
la musique est interdite d'essayer
musique
ça sert à continuer à vivre de sa
passion évidemment mais aussi à attirer
l'attention de la communauté
internationale sur le sort des femmes
afghan merci Steve je me tourne vers
vous Carol Man pour que vous nous
expliquez parce que vous faites partie
de celles et ceux qui se battent pour
les femmes d'Afghanistan sur le terrain
avec cette ONG femme ed vous proposez
quoi des cours clandestins c'est ça oui
je vais vous expliquer je vais revenir à
la problématique de la résistance là on
vient de voir des figures emblématiques
mais il y a une réelle résistance et ces
résistante sont les enseignantes et les
élèves qui bravent les autorités et qui
veulent continuer à apprendre à étudier
à faire quelque chose de leur vie ça
c'est la vraie résistance on la retrouve
aussi en Iran sont celles qui veulent
résister par l'éducation par une forme
d'indépendance c'est peut-être une forme
de résistance mondialisée je pense à
même en RDC
un programme qu'on a mis en place ou des
filles apprennent à se défendre à vous
parce que vous avez mis à distance que
je veux dire c'est que cette résistance
au niveau individuel c'est par
l'éducation et l'apprentissage ce qu'on
a fait avec ma petite association et
maintenant associée à une autre qui
s'appelle naestan on a mis en place des
cours il faut les appeler ceux qui sont
clandestins ou les enseignants de son
pays il y a à peu près 10 000 écoles je
crois bien il y a 10 000 écoles de ce
genre là la centaine dont nous nous
occupons les enseignantes sont payés
suivre des suivent des cours de
formation continue et les élèves elles
font la scolarité elles suivent la
scolarité qu'elles auraient suivies dans
le gouvernement précédent et ça c'est
très important il y a un enthousiasme
absolument fou et tout le monde prend
des risques énormes mais ils ont envie
de prendre ces risques et ses filles et
leurs familles ont compris que leur
avenir était en jeu et l'avenir de toute
la société dépend de cette éducation des
femmes moi j'ai une question depuis le
début de ce débat c'est comment toutes
ces mesures sont accueillies par la
population masculine parce que on
imagine bien comment les talibans ont
pris le pouvoir comment ils peuvent se
maintenir au pouvoir avec des milices
des polices des militaires tout ce qu'on
veut mais il y a un moment pour que ce
système tienne est-ce qu'il y a pas une
forme de d'un sentiment pour ne pas dire
de complicité de la population masculine
lambda cela ne savons faire pour
commencer et ensuite
ce qui on n'a pas vu des millions
d'Afghans dans la rue on aurait voulu on
aurait aimé les amis afghane bien sûr ce
sont dit mais s'ils avaient été 20
millions à marcher pacifiquement les
talibans les aurait pas tous embarqué il
faut comprendre quand même de choses
c'est que avoir la culture de la
manifestation en Afghanistan n'existe
pas du tout comme dans nos pays n'existe
pas je je précise mon propos monsieur
n'existe pas sur ces 20 dernières années
parce que chaque manif se terminait dans
un bain de sang avec des attentats
répétés donc ce n'est pas si facile de
manifester dans le contexte actuel
sachant qu'en plus les talibans qui nous
avait promis quand même un pays sécurisé
en fait même sur la question de la
sécurité ne sont pas capables de la
produire enfin il faut quand même bien
voir que à Kaboul le problème là c'est
évidemment les talibans sont un ennemi
très très facile à détester parce qu'ils
sont détestables mais il faut bien
comprendre et moi je suis à la Kaboul
plus de 10 fois depuis qu'ils sont là il
faut bien comprendre que la rue n'est
pas nécessairement toujours défavorable
au taliban parce que dans un contexte
extrêmement répressif ou les prêches
tous les vendredis se font de plus en
plus dur ou les femmes sont de moins en
moins nombreuses dans la rue et de plus
en plus couverte dans un pays
extrêmement traditionaliste et
patriarcale et bien en fait le
harcèlement de rue ressenti par moments
de façon encore plus aiguë alors vous
avez évidemment des millions de paires
de familles qui pleurent en regardant
leur petit garçon partir à l'école le
matin et avec la fille la petite fille
qui reste au sol et qui elle voilà et
désespérée donc on voit aussi tous ces
hommes bien sûr pris d'empathie surtout
sur la question de l'éducation des vies
parce que là les talibans c'est une
erreur en plus politique majeure ce que
les afons ont quand même énormément
évolué sur la question de l'éducation
des collégiennes et des lycéennes mais
c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas de résistance
au taliban sur la question de la
privation des droits des fans c'est très
clair et on peut difficilement je pense
défendre le contraire votre avis réponse
à la question de Mathieu et puis je
rajoute quelque chose sur effectivement
est-ce qu'il y a au sein des talibans
vous pouvez venir un peu plus tard à
des divergences vous l'avez évoqué tout
à l'heure notamment sur l'éducation des
jeunes d'abord l'espèce de je sais pas
de de complicité passive d'une partie
des hommes dans l'Afghanistan pour
répondre parce que si
tout ça dépend de quel avant on parle
voilà
si vous voulez ici turbaines s'occupe
ont fréquentait des écoles qui
travaillent
oh il y a des tests
rien quoi voir près de 90000 avant que
sont partis
au moment de
l'arrivée totalement montre l'emploi
quand même d'une partie de la population
qui était ce soir mais la connaissance
n'est pas seulement Kaboul n'est pas
seulement des grandes villes n'est pas
seulement 2 millions on estime de
millions des gens qui
avant l'arrivée de détour les bandes
d'une façon ou de l'autre travailler
dans le secteur
non à vos connaissances et 40 millions
de personnes et extrêmement majoritaire
dans les campagnes
alors là dans les campagnes
les petites commerçant de quoi de bazar
et dire MERCI MERCI bio maintenant on a
de la sécurité
voilà je vais vous dire vous savez
encore encore
plus de 45 heures excusez-moi plus de
90% de la population son alphabet
et donc à vous connaissant n'est pas
seulement et ça c'est première point
deuxième point mais que je tenais à
là-dessus
tout ça on a parlé de la résistance
notamment inciter une figure qui était
extrêmement populaire
et respecté pas seulement parce que il a
été la fille de roi Amandine mais
également par ces positions en fait les
femmes à savoir mabouba aujourd'hui il
est détesté pourquoi parce que il a pris
des positions en favorent les bandes
donc la situation est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça on sait sur les
torléans rapidement est-ce qu'il y a un
courant interne au taliban qui qui
serait prêt à
autoriser de nouveaux les jeunes filles
aller à l'école
certains d'entre eux m'ont ils ont même
pris publiquement la parole comme ça qui
a été le principal
négociateurs avec des Américains qui
aujourd'hui
vice Miss des Affaires étrangères à
trois reprises d'une manière publique il
a pris position de la tour mais on sait
qu'il y a un courant et parfois
extrêmement
compliqué c'est à dire quelqu'un qui est
considéré terroriste par les Américains
les Européens chef de réseau akani qui
est ministre de l'Intérieur aujourd'hui
sont grands théorie curieusement
aujourd'hui se situe dans ce courant
dans ce courant vous voyez donc c'est
complexe
de ça parce que ce qui serait
terrorisant aujourd'hui dans la mesure
où personne n'a de prise sur eux
politiquement nous évidemment pas mais
mais pas non plus les pays islamistes
qui va permettre l'éducation à part un
talibans c'est à dire si les talibans
là-dessus ne trouve pas la solution il y
a vraiment pas d'autres solutions que
les écoles clandestine pour les années à
venir mais alors justement vos écoles
j'imagine que vous prenez le plus de
précautions etc mais vous lisez tout à
l'heure grosso modo si j'ai un peu
comprise c'est que si les talibans
voulait fermer ces écoles clandestine
comment vous expliquer ça et bien
d'abord ces écoles ne sont pas dans des
bâtiments
spécifiques ils sont à domicile et en
général la présence d'une école dans un
foyer signifie la protection du chef de
famille et la sentiment de
l'environnement donc déjà comme ça c'est
un espace enfin j'imagine que c'est un
espace parfois négociable avec les
autorités du quoi on a presque pas
d'école dans le fief à candard et dans
les fiefs pachtounes extrême enfin là où
il y a le plus de talibans là on n'est
pas très très présent mais il y a une
protection interne
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'origidité ou
de souplesse les deux à la fois
effectivement les talibans arrivent
parfois et rentre dans les foyers mais
c'est peut-être moins lié à la présence
de filles que peut-être un déjà corps
avec le père de famille ou
l'environnement ou la famille ou
d'autres choses comme ça donc tout le
monde a un Coran à portée de main et
maintenant
et puis de la couture exactement comme
le la première génération des talibans
c'était pareil on fait de la couture on
lit le Coran quand quelqu'un arrive je
vois qu'on ouvre une question sur ce que
ce que nous occidentaux on peut faire ce
que les diplomaties tendent de faire
Matthieu la France a fait le choix
plutôt de partir c'est ça en tout cas
l'arrivée des aliments au pouvoir à
poser une question que j'allais dire
traditionnelle pour les chancelleries
occidentales mais chancellerie dans le
monde qu'est-ce qui se passe quand un
régime pareil au pouvoir est-ce que si
on sanctionne le régime on sanctionne sa
population et puis la seconde question
c'est si jamais on reprend l'angle avec
les talibans est-ce qu'on essaie de
adoucir en leur parlant ou est-ce qu'on
assoit l'ordre légitimité en les
reconnaissant la France a tranché en
tout cas une partie de la première
question en gelant participant sur tout
ce qui est le gel des avoir des
officiels mais en envoyant et en
poursuivant de l'aide humanitaire pour
la population en revanche sur la seconde
question est-ce qu'il faut reconnaître
ou non l'appareil est sur une position
ferme on rappelle que l'ambassade a été
fermé qu'elle est aujourd'hui à Paris
que les deux ambassades qui jouent le
rôle d'accueil des réfugiés quand il y
en a c'est que à l'islamabad et à
Téhéran voilà c'est des donc c'est pour
ça que je dis joue le rôle quand voilà
et que
l'Afghanistan d'une certaine façon a un
peu disparu des radars de la diplomatie
française alors les diplomates qui
œuvrent en coulisse sans doute le
contraire mais du point de vue de nous
citoyens on se souvient de l'allocution
d'Emmanuel Macron souvenez-vous en
pleine vacances le 16 août 2021 à la
télévision une allocution pour parler de
l'Afghanistan avec un message
l'Afghanistan ne doit pas redevenir le
sanctuaire du terr et on appelant une
forme de coalition de internationale
pour faire pression mais aujourd'hui
quand on voit je regardais aujourd'hui
sur le site du Quai d'Orsay il y a des
protestations et des condamnations
officielles de la France on a peut-être
deux à trois par mois alors condamnation
sur le sort qui est réservé aux femmes
ou condamnation sur la liberté
d'expression qui n'est pas mais d'une
certaine façon le débat reste entier a
lancé que au sein de l'Europe il y a des
voies un peu discordantes on n'a pas
forcément la même position que
l'Allemagne ou que les Pays-Bas mais
nous notre position retranché au nom des
principes qui est d'une certaine façon
l'inverse de la réelle politique fait
qu'on s'est mis un petit peu hors-jeu
diplomatiquement rapide là-dessus très
rapidement oui malheureusement la France
est au jour en Afghanistan mais
même s'il y a énormément de ne sont pas
reconnu par aucun pays aucun pays mais
la réalité est que l'état des bandes
avec certains pays notamment avec des
grands puissances ils ont établi des
relations presque off iciel
on peut citer la Chine en positive la
Russie semble parler du Pakistan qui qui
soutenait on peut parler de l'Iran on
peut parler de la Turquie de l'arrivée
subite c'est-à-dire que dans le jour
politique on assiste aujourd'hui dans le
monde
alors les Américains ne je ne sais pas
comment ils vendent on dirait comme ils
veulent la Chine
alors que il
absente de la connaissance et la raison
pour laquelle c'est les raisons pour
laquelle les États-Unis ont fait des
gestes envers des talons
actuellement chaque semaine 40 millions
de dollars 40 millions de dollars par
semaine vont en espèces on a
connaissance pour se tenir évidemment
pour militaires au menu humanitaire mais
c'est pour soutenir le monnaie à la
grande donc les Américains n'ont pas
renoncé complètement avant contrairement
à la France c'est intéressant
effectivement on va regarder un extrait
de votre
documentaire documentaire donc intitulé
afghane qui a été diffusé il y a
quelques jours tel 12 mars sur eux sur
France 5 c'est le témoignage de
l'ancienne ministre délégué au droit des
femmes du gouvernement d'amis de Kerzaï
et alors j'ai trouvé ça intéressant
parce que ça nous ramène quelques
décennies en arrière elle se souvient de
de la situation des femmes à l'époque du
chat dans les années 70
[Musique]
nous avions tous nos droits les filles
étaient autorisées à l'école et à
l'université nous avions des
enseignantes nous avions des femmes au
Parlement il y avait des femmes dans les
cabinets ministériels
tout en respectant nos anciens nous nous
habillons comme des femmes modernes nous
avions des jupes personne ne faisait de
remarques sur notre tenue
il y avait beaucoup de respect pour les
femmes
vous avez un peu répondu tout à l'heure
mais mais ça c'est une vision c'est quoi
c'est Kaboul et encore on dit dans le on
dit bien dans le sujet et c'est aussi
pour ça que les communistes en réalité
dont évidemment le bilan est plus que
que sanguinaire en Afghanistan mais les
communistes eux après le chat ils se
sont beaucoup plus ouverts ils ont les
programmes d'éducation populaire ont
énormément touché en réalité les
campagnes la tajoie parle d'un en fait
d'un âge d'or un âge enchanté mais qui
n'a touché qui a touché les capitales
provinciales quand même et pas
simplement les filles à la fac quand
vous voyez des images de filles à
candard et à ton 12 avec des jupes en
dessous du genou mais qui sont
sages-femmes qui sont pas voyez
professeur je sais pas moi en biologie
donc c'est ça qui est un peu en fait qui
est intéressant avec l'Afghanistan et
que moi je voulais vraiment montrer dans
mon film c'est à dire que vous mais vous
dépliez une frise sous vos yeux et vous
avez l'impression que vous pouvez
enlever comme ça 20 ans ici 20 ans là
vous vous collez les morceaux vous
aspirez une parenthèse entière et et là
c'est très très présent avec les
aliments les femmes des villes vous
racontent et pardon mais ces deux tiers
de la population qui vit en ruralité et
il reste quand même un gros tiers dans
les villes donc ces gens-là ont vu leur
vie complètement transformer et
reviennent au 20 ans de l'année à 20 ans
20 ans plutôt je voudrais juste dire
quelque chose pardon je sais que vous
voulez qu'on aille vite mais le sujet
c'est les désespoir des femmes afghane
on parlait des sanctions tout à l'heure
il faut quand même comprendre que les
sanctions
que sur lesquels en fait personne encore
une fois ne se penche trop puisque
encore une fois les talibans sont
tellement faciles à détester les
sanctions ça fait quand même que infinie
les gens qui souffrent le plus en
Afghanistan qui sont je le rappelle pas
que les femmes les petites filles
également vous allez vous faites
n'importe quelle étude dans n'importe
quelle province les femmes et les filles
dans des situations de vulnérabilité
sont nourris après les hommes et les
petits garçons donc en fait ce sont les
femmes les filles qui souffrent du fait
que les transferts financiers paralysent
complètement cette économie je le
rappelle les talibans ils sont pas chef
d'entreprise et ils sont pas ingénieurs
quand vous paralysez complètement un
système privé une économie privée pas
simplement avec des sanctions qui font
que si vous avez envie d'aider l'école
les écoles de caroleman vous pouvez pas
le faire ce soir parce que vous pouvez
même pas envoyer d'argent mais aussi
parce que les avoir de la Banque
centrale d'Afghanistan donc on parle
quand même de l'argent des Afghans reste
bloqués aujourd'hui entre les États-Unis
et la Suisse et personne ne questionne
ça et ça c'est quand même difficile
parce que c'est aussi notre
responsabilité on était pays donateurs
on a fait partie de tous ces pays qui
pendant 20 ans ont assumé 40% du PIB de
ce pays et du jour au lendemain on
retire nos billes alors que je rappelle
qu'on a quand même tout fait pour que
les aliments reviennent et on trouve ça
parfaitement normal et personne ne se
questionne sur l'impact sur les femmes
de notre propre politique en fait à ce
niveau là une forme de grand hypocrisie
de la communauté internationale depuis
juillet 21 en fait oui hypocrisie enfin
aveuglement volontaire donc je voudrais
simplement élaborer sur quelque chose
que cela ne vient de dire qu'est-ce que
ça signifie des femmes qui payent quand
on a pas d'argent en Afghanistan
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec le système des
dotes la dot et payer par l'homme pour
pour j'allais dire acheter la femme il y
a même un mot pour ça personne Shiba aïe
le prix du lait donc comme c'est
rentable d'avoir une fille on les vend
très très jeunes il y a des bébés qui
ont été vendus et on attend qu'elles
soient pubère ou même pas pour les avoir
chez chez eux enfin pour que le mari
puisse la prendre alors le résultat
c'est quoi une mortalité maternelle qui
est déjà qui est déjà été la pire au
monde il y a 20 ans c'est en train de
redevenir comme ça quand on a des
petites filles de 11-12 ans qui
accouchent et il y a pas de sage-femme
et ainsi de suite des bébés des mamans
dénutri qui accouche et qui meurt en
accouchant ça c'est une des conséquences
et ça on veut pas le voir parce que
l'argent doit bien venir de quelque part
donc si on peut pas faire autrement on
vend sa fille merci beaucoup on va
terminer là-dessus le débat est terminé
merci d'y avoir participé aux uns et aux
autres je vais je vais rappeler Solène
Chelon fiority le titre de votre livre
la femme qui s'est éveillée qui est
publié aux éditions Flammarion on peut
aider votre votre ONG ça m'aide
l'adresse c'est famed.org c'est ça tout
à fait si vous êtes sensible au thème de
cette émission allez-y
www.famade.org merci à toutes et à tous
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée sur
l'antenne de public Senna et noter que
demain l'invité politique de rien de
Mancini ce sera le vice-président du
parti LR François-Xavier mais l'ami
député européen bonne soirée
[Musique]